Hey guys.
My name is Shallon and I'm here to help you with all the questions you might have...
...about love, lust, romance, and everything in between.
For more, visit me on Twitter @downtownshallon...
...or be sure to check out my website, shallononline.com.
There's nothing creepy or sketchy about meeting somebody on an online dating site,...
...but that doesn't mean that there's not creepy and sketchy people...
...on the online dating site.
Here's a few things to look out for.
Remember, there's no limit to how much somebody can lie.
If a guy says he's 17,...
...a lot of girls are like, "Well, he's you know maybe 18 or 19."
No, he could be 50.
People lie and they lie big.
Also, don't give out too much of your personal information.
A guy doesn't need your e-mail, your address, your phone number,...
...your Twitter handle, your Facebook page,...
...real in the contact that someone can have.
You never know where something is going to lead...
...and once you give someone that info it can't be taken back.
It's really important to listen to your gut and your instinct,...
...if you get kind of a bad feeling about somebody or anything.
A respectable guy isn't gonna get mad that you want to postpone the meeting...
...or maybe talk on the phone a little bit first...
...or bring one of your friends along.
A real man understands that it's important for a woman to feel safe,...
...so don't be afraid to set limits and listen to your instincts...
...because if you don't...
...and you're just so flattered that he's giving you attention,...
...it might be the wrong kind of attention.
He might have a van with a tiger airbrushed on the side of it.
Is that a chance you wanna take?
I don't think so.